This is the universe.
And this little.here is the earth,
and this is a big bounce coming up.
And it's about to squash our planet.
How long would we have until the earth got crushed into nothingness?
What would we observe from down here and what would happen
next?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if the universe was bouncing,
it's generally accepted that the universe emerged from one single point of
infinite density and then rapidly expanded in what we call the big
bang. But when it happened,
nobody was around to see it for themselves.
So here comes a new theory.
What if it all didn't start with the big bang
13.8 billion years ago? What if instead,
the universe had no beginning and no end,
but it was expanding and contracting back over and over again.
The cyclical universe involves a series of big bouncers where
the universe acts like an enormous cosmic lung inhaling and
exhaling a giant breath with every bounce. Basically,
you've got nothing to worry about because the cyclic universe expands for
several billion years and then contracts for billions of
years on a scale of a human lifespan.
This timeline is just not developing fast enough to affect you in any way.
But we here at what F like to add some spice to our stories in this case,
we'll speed things up and have the universe go through its bouncing cycle almost
every day.
And the next bouncing event is scheduled for tomorrow.
You'd start the day with some worrisome news from astrophysicists,
the stars and galaxies that normally move slowly away from each other
would now be moving toward one another and fast.
Every planet star and every galaxy on the edge of the universe would be
rushing towards its center. Breaking the cosmic Lightspeed limit.
Black holes would be colliding with other black holes.
They'd be sending huge amounts of cosmic radiation in all directions and
growing into even bigger black holes.
Nope. Planet in the universe would have a stable orbit anymore.
They'd go flying across the galaxy to meet up at the cosmic downtown.
At this point,
things would get quite messy on our planet and you wouldn't be able to do a
thing to stop it. So who just sit back.
I see the world and
as the universe continued to collapse in on itself,
its temperature would rapidly become hotter. The soup.
Heated temperatures would evaporate our oceans, our planet,
and even our atoms.
Everything that ever existed would be wiped out.
Finally, when the universe can practice to its densest point,
it would become a super hot dense mix of matter.
It would slow down for a moment and then suddenly start expanding again.
A new bouncing cycle would begin a totally new universe would
emerge new universe,
old rules from hot cosmic dust.
Gravity would form new planets, new stars and new galaxies.
And then new life forms would emerge on these new worlds.
This new universe would expand until it reaches its limit.
And then it would go back to becoming a dense hot ball of matter.
The cycle would repeat and again and again,
but we would be too long gone to know about it.
Well that turned out a bit dark, but Hey,
the universe is only 13.8 billion years old.
We've got a few billion more until the contraction will begin.
And honestly, it's quite a deep topic to dive into.
We've got more questions and there's no one better to ask them to then
the very person who developed this cyclical model of the universe
on what if discussed? We talked to Dr. Anna,
[inaudible] a theoretical physicist at the max Planck Institute for
gravitational physics.
Check it out to learn more about the big bounce and how dark matter fits into
it.